well that was interesting cow talk let's
let's go back to school
we got this story from timcast.com
former assistant principal at virginia
elementary school files lawsuit says
critical race theory teachings created
really hostile work environment really
who worked at agnor hurt elementary
school in charlottesville says she was
subjected to extreme harassment for
weeks over her reservations about crt
the situation escalated for maes maes
she claims that she accidentally used
the word colored instead of people of
color during a teaching workshop despite
apologizing continuously including
immediately after the word was uttered
she says that for months she was
harassed and berated by other staff and
that the district failed to intervene
one black employee who refused to accept
the apology began referring to her as
that white racist bee
wow
you know i just got to say
this is a strategy to use
if you work somewhere with any kind of
critical race theory stuff sue him
that's what you got to do because if if
they're telling you things based on race
like white people white privilege or
whatever they're in violation of the
eeoc and the civil rights act so you got
to sue them this is this is this this is
the tactic you got to use it check out
this other story we got this one from
fox news professor wins lost it against
university over pronouns
students demand went against my
christian beliefs the ohio professor won
400 000
after suing the university over being
forced to use students preferred
pronouns there it is my friends
you got to stand up for yourself the
difference between the united states and
canada right there how does the i still
my favorite part about the pronouns
thing is it should very rarely be coming
up in person conversation anyways
because
most of the time you're not using their
pronouns when you're actually talking to
them in the room anyways right you're
gonna call them by their name or you're
gonna refer to them directly it's more
to control your speech when they're not
in the room not weird uh like we were we
did a story on uh on pop culture crisis
where we we were talking about uh demi
lovato and demi lovato has like they
them pronouns and i couldn't do it i
kept screwing it up and because because
like you said earlier i want to be
respectful i try to like some people
don't like that like i'm like look
that's what they want i understand
but i eventually like had to give up on
the point
and come back to it like the next day
because i couldn't get it right i
couldn't i kept screwing it up so she
was controlling she i just did it right
there she they were controlling my
ability to speak on them without even
being in the room just by virtue of uh
creating pronouns that are different
from the normal you know the normal set
so everybody called out demi lovato
because demi lovato says they are
daddy's girl
in caption of sizzling instagram
portraits after coming out as non-binary
and using they them pronouns you don't
get to choose your pronouns i'm sorry i
got i got look i try to be nice to
everybody i want to be civil respectful
but you can't tell me what words to use
if i want to call brett brought
he can be like that's not my name and
i'll be like too bad like i'm going to
say whatever i want i want now is that
short for bratwurst
hey you're not the first what's he going
to do about it
just laughs so so if i say i'm you know
like luke kept calling lydia linda yeah
she's on the show rude first of all see
well she's offended i am very friendly
that means i have to take over calling
you lydia linda now linda no but like
what's what's lady gonna say other than
don't call me linda and he's like okay
linda
like what are you what are you gonna do
it's like you can tell them
to be fair i think that pronouns are
very much a power play because brett's
right there is no period of time at what
you would say like he would braxton
sitting right there in front of you or
when tim's sitting right in front of you
it's when they're not even there it's
like could you could you imagine having
a conversation like that where you're
talking to someone
makes a reference to a demi lovato story
and then i just look to braxton and i'm
like did you hear what he was just
saying oh my gosh
he's just out of the conversation
i think if it's pretty i mean rude for
sure if someone called me by the wrong
name to make fun of me i'd be like all
right bro take it easy and then if they
kept doing it i'd be like i'm not gonna
interact with you anymore uh or or
whatever i had to do
but
i and it's so i understand why but but
then if i i change my pronoun to a new
kind of language or new kind of thought
thing that's a hard one to get i don't
know maybe it's the same kind of thing
that emotionally for the people that are
experiencing this
so
i don't know i don't know man it's well
like remember when it was it on here or
was it on rogan when the labonte on and
he was talking about yeah like i'll call
you by your pronouns but i might just
not call you very often to hang out
because you're really difficult to be
around like i don't mean any disrespect
but like if i have to worry about any
point in the conversation something like
this comes up i'm just i'm just gonna
check out dude i'm just not interested
i'm not interested in it yeah the way to
put it i mean how mad are you at your
dad you know like that's
like how much do you need attention i
don't think it's that demi lovato said
she's daddy's girl yeah she she you know
what i'm saying she why because she said
she's daddy's girl yeah and now i've
look if she comes out and says that
she's non-binary i'm like okay whatever
if she comes out and says she's dating
his girl i'm like oh she's a girl again
she's good so now she's a she right you
can't like so she changed it back so
pronoun fluid yeah yeah well yeah yeah
she's just she can just be pronounced
no you don't think it is the reason why
they're going after kids is because
little kids are like trying to find
their identity right but the identity is
usually something like do i want to be a
fireman or do i want to be a carpenter
do i want to be a doctor or a nurse or
something now they're going to kids and
be like
i remember when i was little like what's
your favorite color and i was always
like i don't know like how do you know
what your favorite color is what does
that even mean and then i would just
tell people green because the calendar
of mar for march my birthday was always
greens like green i guess because like
that's the only thing i can kind of
think of i don't know i kind of like
blue or whatever
so you just pick it
now you're a little kid and they're like
which pronouns are you and they're like
floorbo
is it uh is it new york that recognizes
33 separate genders 31 31 separate
genders it's uh it's insane but they
they legally recognize any and all
genders which means you can make one up
on the spot so what is the point of a 31
if if they legally recognize all of the
31 they even are redundant like female
to male is considered a gender in in new
york but ftm is also considered a gender
even though it means the same thing
this stuff is so difficult to talk about
because i am such a generally respectful
and do not want to offend or hurt
anyone's feelings and i know a lot of
people like working here you kind of
like p a lot of people see that as like
a flaw right that you're like you're too
weak to
to stand up for something but it's like
i don't want to offend or upset anybody
but some of this stuff is so impossible
to process in the moment that if i can't
even have a a reasonable conversation
with you i don't know how to do this
without being offensive and i don't want
that so it's like i'm being forced to be
offensive but only to them
like i'm trying not to be but they're
making it about that and that's very
very difficult for me to process as
somebody who just doesn't want to be on
the wrong side of people just for
general reasons yeah talking about
someone that's that then you're then
you're taking some risk when you're
talking to someone it doesn't pronouns
are out of the que you don't even use
pronouns you're having a conversation
with somebody and anyone can get down
with that doesn't matter how they
identify when you start talking about
people then they're like whoa if you're
going to bring me into this bring me
into it the way i want to be brought
into it and that's like not in the
united states i'm bringing you in
because you're part of this uh and i
think it's you can have that discussion
it's it's purposefully destabilizing
yeah it's it's impossible for a regular
person to know what's happening or who
you're talking about so the example i
gave like on twitter was
i i can't remember exactly how i wrote
it but i said pat and sam
go to see a movie
they got angry
because they wanted to see a horror film
but they ended up seeing a comedy
instead and what they really wanted was
and it's just like what is that they
refer to like which person did what if
you said like mike and jane went to a
movie she got angry because she wanted
to see a comedy film but he wanted to
see horror and they ended up seeing
horror now you understand the girlfriend
is mad she wants the comedy the
boyfriend want to see horror they were
both mad because they didn't i'm seeing
anything but if you said sam and pat
went to the movies they were mad because
they wanted to see a comedy but they saw
horror it's like are you like they were
both mad
which which which person is referred to
in the they
now to be fair in the context of you
know sarah and jane go to the movie and
she was mad you're also like i don't
know which person you're referring to
because if it's two different genders
there you go in which in which case you
don't need the pronouns at all
sarah and jen go to the movies sarah got
mad because she because she wanted to
see a movie a comedy but jane wanted to
see horror and they ended up saying so
you just use the name in which case this
whole discussion is like
i think you're right though that it is
that it's about being purposely
destabilizing as much as it pains me to
give him credit jesse kelly calls these
guys uh communists all the time and i
think he's right at least in orientation
and also because it makes him mad to be
called communist so i think it's good to
use but
uh the whole you know basically the in a
sense the lenin model is de-stable uh
destabilize create confusion and chaos
and then come in and be the person that
restores order in the way that you want
it and that seems to be the approach
how do they restore or who do who are
they looking for people in the streets
but i'm saying who are they looking for
that's going to make sense of this well
at this stage
at this stage i don't think it matters
because it's chaos stages because he's
like a lot of these people who shield
for for biden who just like like he
doesn't understand this stuff he doesn't
like i would argue that he doesn't
really understand any of the stuff
that's going on with that type of with
that part of the movement but it's like
you said earlier you think it's about
destabilizing and we talked about
religion and you said i think like why
why does it feel like people are coming
more uh around to religion again because
they're looking for something solid
under their feet and i'm not religious
but i'm one of those people that's like
everything feels so up in the air now
that you're just looking for something
anything to hold on to that feels like
some semblance of the real world and not
this postmodern hell that feels like
we're in right now yeah i mentioned that
earlier that in a time when you start to
lose faith in reality you start to look
for faith in other places and i see
people
reverting to religion of the past or to
what non-binary degenerism or whatever
the heck
i looked up there's a meme going around
it says they translated non-binary into
spanish and there's two ways to
translate it one is the feminine version
and one is the masculine version
wow thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there